ask question but we're wondering how
closely you're watching the situation in
Sudan
I'm watching it very closely indeed and
I urge people to pray for that country
and for South Sudan which of course is
very impacted by what happens in Sudan
um over last weekend I was at a
conference in Kenya in Nairobi and I met
president Ruto and we in order
specifically to talk about how
that wonderful nation of Kenya can help
with the process of Peace in South Sudan
and Sudan I'm watching it carefully we
need to pray for it's a horrific
situation I've been in touch with
the Christian leaders there it's
terrifying
and it's another reason I think for on
Saturday
here is
a coronation which is an emblem of
stability of solidity
where what happens there is far far away
but not beyond our compassion and the
real concern is hundreds of thousands of
refugees and the destabilization of the
area now it's the destabilization of
what is already
um as someone said in a speech at this
conference on Saturday
a rough neighborhood you've got Somalia
and Eritrea you've got Ethiopia you've
got Central African Republic the DRC
uh you've got the whole Sahel
it's
it is really concerning and the
suffering of Ordinary People is
Beyond
comprehension the leaders there must
come to a ceasefire and arrange for
mediation they must do it and they must
do it quickly